the climate conference of coping has
been discussed here Eddie Martin devils
and I to we are to meet very very
important that we don't keep up with our
feelings over and over now I think this
year shall be used to realize that we
did not obtain what we wanted to get of
the individual are forgettin but we have
to get it still so this the conference
intervals I think the green economy
economy has to be accepted as a new way
of heavy fuel economy of the future the
green economy will create jobs and will
help in an influence upon the climate so
my hope is up to a mexico next december
that we will not forget that we still
have to get results in the climate
conference join this year